The newest adaptation of Stephen King's It
took a few creative liberties with the story
setting and events, so it's probably no surprise
that some of the characters described in the
1986 novel don't come through quite same as
they'd been written.
Although the Losers and their nemeses certainly
carry the spirit of the source material through
to the big screen, let's take a look at how
they stack up to the book's original descriptions.
Bill Denbrough
Jaeden Lieberher was previously seen in Midnight
Special and Showtime's Masters of Sex before
becoming Bill Denbrough for It.
Bill — also known as Stuttering Bill — is
the de facto leader of the Losers' Club and
is described as having a "goofball grin" and
anxious blue eyes.
He's also the tallest and most authoritative
member of the group.
After the group's childhood years, he'd later
be compared to a teenage JFK for his reddish
hair.
Onscreen, Lieberher looks quite different
than the Bill described in the book.
He's not particularly taller or more imposing
than the others, but he still makes it clear
he's the one who's lost the most — and has
the most at stake down in the sewers.
He doesn't have book-Bill's shock of red hair,
either.
Considering he manages to pull off Bill's
passion for the Pennywise chase, however,
it still works.
Richie Tozier
Stranger Things star Finn Wolfhard doubled
down on his '80s horror appeal by starring
as Richie Tozier, the scrawny, bespectacled
kid who makes up what he lacks in size with
zingers.
In the book, Richie is described as having
such oversized teeth that he earns the nickname
"Bucky Beaver," and has lenses so thick that
he'd be blind without them.
Those glasses are also constantly being broken,
dropped, kicked, and bent in the book, and
they're almost always lopsided and mended
with tape.
And his mouth constantly gets him into trouble,
which is what earns him the childhood nickname
"Trashmouth."
Since most of the book's physical descriptions
of Richie revolve around his glasses and chompers,
Wolfhard is halfway there to perfection.
He might not have those prominent teeth, but
his specs and sass are definitely on point.
Ben Hanscom
Relative newcomer Jeremy Ray Taylor may be
familiar to fans of the Marvel Universe thanks
to his role as a bully in Ant-Man.
In It, however, he made a change of pace by
playing Ben Hanscom, the boy who's actually
on the receiving end of so many taunts.
Ben is described as wearing very loose-fitting
clothing because of the constant ridicule
he receives for his weight.
Inside, he's a very sweet, intelligent, and
dependable dude, but all anyone can see when
they look at him is his size.
He's estimated to weigh around 150 to 160
pounds and seems quite insecure about his
appearance.
In the role, Taylor pulls off not just the
physical attributes of Ben, but the emotional
presence of the character as well.
Beverly Marsh
Sophia Lillis is a relative newcomer to the
movie business, but fans of It won't soon
forget her name.
Starring as Beverly Marsh, the lone lady of
the Loser's Club, Lillis manages to bring
forth some of the subtler qualities of the
character that hadn't quite been seen in the
1990 TV mini-series adaptation.
In Stephen King's original version, Beverly
is described as being less financially fortunate
than the others — a fact that comes through
in her wardrobe, with her thrift-store clothes
and scuffed shoes.
From the boys' perspective, she's described
as being very pretty, with hair that is long
and auburn, eyes that are grayish green, and
a pale complexion.
She's also got a smattering freckles and a
smile that is seen as "wise, cynical, and
sad all at the same time."
For all those reasons, Lillis' casting is
essentially perfect.
Although her long hair does look a little
false in the beginning of the movie, she still
pulls off the look with convincing poise.
More importantly, she captures that subtle
strength and world-weariness that made the
character such a force in the novel.
"I can take that."
Eddie Kaspbrak
Jack Dylan Grazer capped a brief string of
early supporting roles with the part of Eddie
Kaspbrak, one of Bill's longtime closest friends
and a charter member of the Losers' Club.
Most of King's descriptions of Eddie center
around his asthma.
Plagued by his helicopter mom, he's small,
slight, and fragile — even as an adult,
when his face is described as "thin and delicate-looking."
Eddie doesn't get much of a physical description
in the book, so there weren't many ways the
filmmakers could go wrong.
While Grazer's Eddie looks entirely different
than the 1990s version, he still captures
his character's apparent frailties while still
being a lot stronger than he looks.
Mike Hanlon
Hawaii Five-O vet Chosen Jacobs traded the
tropics for Maine when he took on the role
of It's Mike Hanlon.
A farm kid growing up on the outskirts of
town, Mike is from the only black family in
Derry and is constantly tormented by Henry
Bowers and his bully crew.
As described in the book, Mike has been toughened
up by physically laborious work, and is fast,
agile, and slim.
Jacobs is a brilliant casting choice for Mike.
Not only does he have the big, tough, farm
kid physicality in play, but he also has an
emotional vulnerability that makes his narrative
arc so much more interesting to watch unfold.
Stan Uris
You might recognize Wyatt Oleff as the young
Star-Lord in the Guardians of the Galaxy movies,
but there's no doubt everyone will remember
him now as Stanley Uris from It.
In the book, Stanley is described as having
black hair and a nose that doesn't quite suit
the stereotype for a person of the Jewish
faith.
He's also a little older than the other children
due to being held back a grade as a kid.
Oleff's version doesn't have the black hair
that Stan's described to have in the novel.
But he does have his fussy mannerisms, neatness,
and sense of shaken faith down to a science.
Henry Bowers
It's secondary antagonist Henry Bowers is
only 12 in the book, but he looks much bigger
to the Losers because of the fact that he's
flunked enough to still be in their same grade.
Unlike the film, which moves the action to
the '80s, the book is set in the '50s.
And Henry is the embodiment of the prototypical
bully from that era, with a flat top haircut,
a pink motorcycle jacket, and the physical
wear of his father's heavy hand.
For the 2017 version, Nicholas Hamilton's
Henry Bowers got a complete wardrobe overhaul
to match the new time period, and instead
of the slick hairstyle, he sports a mullet.
The new Henry Bowers is still just as classically
mean as prior versions, though, so that's
what counts.
Patrick Hockstetter
Although Henry Bowers was bad enough, his
sidekick Patrick was really horrible at his
core.
Played by Owen Teague from Bloodline and Black
Mirror, Patrick is the student who triggers
a whole different level of fear in those he
terrorizes with his wandering hands and pencil
case full of dead flies.
In the novel, he's heavyset with a "slack
and pallid moonface."
One of his teachers even describes him as
"a big lump of clay that had been crudely
fashioned to look like a boy."
He's also the kind of completely deranged
guy who would murder his infant brother in
his crib.
Teague, who already has a slew of credits
to his name, looks nothing like the heavyset,
expressionless pre-teen of the book.
And in the film version, the essence of the
character has been dialed down dramatically
to the point that he's really no more than
a schoolyard bully with an aerosol fire gun.
Pennywise
Although he's scary in his own right, Bill
Skarsgård's Pennywise represents a significant
visual change from the novel.
His new costuming was inspired by Elizabethan
and medieval-era clown and jester costumes
rather than the baggy silver suit with orange
buttons that's described in King's book.
King also describes him as having yellow eyes,
and reminds poor Georgie of Bozo the clown.
He's later compared to Ronald McDonald for
his painted-white face and massive smile,
and in addition to his long, sharp teeth,
he's also mostly bald, except for an orangish-red
tuft of hair on each side of his head.
The Pennywise of the movie doesn't quite resemble
what King originally imagined — but he's
still the kind of clown you wouldn't want
to run across at a carnival, so it works.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!